This is what it looks like to drive
through Wyoming… for about 400 miles.
About the only thing you’ll see during
the first four and a half hours are
the towns of Rock Springs and Rawlins,
populations: 23,000 and 8,000, respectively.
Hopefully you aren’t prone to
boredom because, quite frankly,
there’s nothing to see. Despite
being larger than the United Kingdom,
Wyoming is home to less than 600,000 people
– about 17% of 1% of the U.S. population.
And this emptiness is no accident.
Sponsored by Nebula, the exclusive
home to my Original series “China,
Actually”. Stay tuned for
a new episode coming soon.
Coal is the lifeblood of Wyoming.
The Cowboy State alone produces 40%
of America’s supply – three times
more than 2nd place West Virginia and
over 50% more than all of Appalachia.
The North Antelope Rochelle Mine in the state’s
Northeast corner is the largest open-pit coal mine
in the world. It operates on two 12-hour
shifts, rain or shine, 365 days a year.
Without it, the economy, and, indeed, the
Wyoming way of life, would soon collapse.
Though not, as you might assume, for lack of jobs.
Truth be told, there are only about
5,000 coal miners left in the state.
The loss of these high-paying jobs certainly
wouldn’t help, but even the incomprehensibly
massive North Antelope Mine only employs about
1,100 people – 0.1% of the state’s population.
No, the real reason Wyoming
needs coal are severance taxes.
For every hundred dollars worth of coal, oil,
and gas produced in the state, between six
and six and a half dollars are siphoned into the
public purse, creating an enormous budget surplus.
Rather than redistribute this
wealth directly as annual dividends,
as Alaska does, the people of
Wyoming have chosen low taxes.
In any given year, its average household
pays only about $3,500 in property, sales,
and use taxes, but receives about $27,000
worth of services – including education,
healthcare, and infrastructure.
In other words, Wyoming residents
receive an 80-90% discount on
public services – all thanks to fossil fuels.
But this unusual arrangement
has some unusual implications.
Imagine you move to, say, North Dakota.
This line represents your contributions to
the state in the form of taxes, and this
one, the services you receive in return.
What this graph, by the economist
Dr. Peter Evangelakis, shows is that
new residents have a slightly positive
effect on the state budget. On average,
and in the vast majority of states,
newcomers give more than they take.
Now let’s say you move to nearby Wyoming.
There, you’d still consume one person’s-worth
of resources. Yet, because its tax rates are so
low, you wouldn’t add much additional revenue.
New residents are a massive drain on its budget.
Coal is finite. The larger the population,
the less pie is left for everyone.
Simply put: its taxpayers have a uniquely
strong incentive to keep their state empty.
While nearly every region of America has slowly
urbanized – including Red states like Arkansas,
Texas, and Idaho – Wyoming stands apart as one
of the last true remnants of the Wild West.
In 1980, it was the 49th most populous state
in the Union. Today, it’s the 50th. In those
40 years, its net population grew by
just 2,552 people a year on average.
There is no Austin, Texas island
of liberalism, or Bentonville,
Arkansas pocket of urban growth. Every
inch of Wyoming remains just… Wyoming.
And this resistance to change is
not limited to demographic growth.
Take, clean energy, for example.
In the last 15 years, wind farms have rapidly
proliferated across the United States – and not
just including but especially in traditionally
Red states like Texas, Oklahoma, and Kansas.
But not Wyoming.
Between 2011 and 19, the amount of wind power
generated by the Cowboy State actually decreased
by nearly 10% as few new turbines were
built while many were taken out of service.
In a 2023 survey of 8 Western states – 5 Red
and 3 Blue – Wyoming was the only one where a
majority of respondents preferred to “maximize”,
not “reduce the need” for coal, oil, and gas.
Wyoming makes Montana look like a
bastion of Prius-driving liberals.
But all this may be about to change.
On August 30th, 2022, it became clear California
was about to experience one of
its hottest weeks in history.
100 plus degree temperatures were forecast every
day for the Greater Los Angeles region
– home to nearly 20 million Americans.
Extreme heat would surely lead to extreme use
of air conditioning – one of the
biggest consumers of electricity.
This line represents energy use on a typical
Summer day. This one, the record for all
of 2021. And these, actual usage between
August 31st and September 6th last year.
At the same time, electricity
supply was seriously constrained.
Blistering temperatures led to
droughts. Droughts led to wildfires,
and wildfires to smoke, which reduced the
efficiency of solar panels by roughly 30%.
Droughts also brought water levels to
record lows in reservoirs across the state,
including the Hoover Dam’s Lake Mead, a major
source of power for Southern California.
If this unusually large demand looked
as though it might exceed this unusually
low supply – even momentarily – state officials
would have no choice but to initiate blackouts.
And, on Tuesday, this nightmare
scenario seemed inevitable.
By late afternoon, Sacramento, San Jose,
Santa Rosa, Redwood City, Livermore,
Napa, and King City had all tied or
broken their all-time heat records.
Sports games were canceled,
recess was held inside,
and BART trains operated at reduced
speeds in case tracks were warped by heat.
A few minutes before 5, as Californians
began returning home from work,
demand for electricity set a new state
record, flirting with the edge of supply.
In a panic, Governor Gavin Newsom
sent an emergency text message,
begging residents to reduce their usage.
Either thousands of households would
voluntarily turn down their ACs on the
hottest day of the year, or the state was about to
experience its third major blackout in 20 years.
It worked. Barely. Within minutes,
about 2,000 megawatts of demand
disappeared, narrowly averting crisis.
But harder times lie ahead.
Like many states, California is
planning for a clean energy future.
By 2026, half of its electricity
must come from renewable sources,
followed by 60% in 2030, and 100% by 2045.
That means a greater reliance on solar and
hydro power – both of which are weakened
at the precise moment energy use is
at its highest – hot summer days.
To achieve its climate goals without repeating the
events of last September, California needs help.
In short: there’s a huge market for the right
kind of energy at the right time of day.
And Wyoming, it turns out, has
just what California needs.
Cruel, relentless wind is
a fact of life in Wyoming.
Its narrow mountain ranges and high
plateaus create thousands of natural
funnels for jet streams, which blow
wind Eastward across the United States.
When these funnels are perpendicular to highways,
as is the case here on I-25 south of Wheatland,
winds can so violently strike the side of
a car – or semi-truck – as to flip it over.
This happens surprisingly frequently,
as seen in this video, which resulted
– miraculously – in zero injuries.
With its high-altitude prairie and sparse human
habitation, there’s simply nothing to slow wind
down, allowing it to reach 65 miles an hour or
faster, at which point roads are typically closed.
While this effect creates some white-knuckle
driving, it’s perfect for wind farms.
Wind speeds are classified between
1 (poor) and 7 (superb). Half of all
6 and 7-class wind in the nation is
located in Wyoming. And most of that
in just a few counties around
the state’s southeast corner.
Not only that, but its wind is strong when
California’s is the weakest – right here
in the afternoon. And when the sun is down on the
West Coast, the Wyoming wind is working overtime.
This unlikely alliance – between
the country’s largest and one of
its most liberal states and its smallest,
most conservative one – has the potential
to radically transform the American West.
The only thing that stands in the way is
an arduous bureaucratic maze of federal,
state, and county regulations.
In 2010, the state of Wyoming re-classified wind
farms as “industrial facilities”, requiring that
they go through the same permitting process as
those involving, for example, radioactive waste.
Only after submitting a 400+ page application,
paying up to $100,000 in fees, and holding
a public hearing, can a wind developer
proceed to step two: submitting another
application, this time to the county.
At any point in this process, any person
or organization with a Wyoming address can
challenge the permit – giving NIMBYs
free rein to slow or halt progress.
Then there’s the federal bureaucracy.
No fewer than six such departments administer
Wyoming land – mainly the
Bureau of Land Management.
In the 1880s, the U.S. government
incentivized the construction of new
railroads by granting those companies land on
either side of the tracks. In hopes that this
land would then be sold to individual
settlers rather than large companies,
it was given to the railroads in
alternating square-mile sections.
The result is a checkerboard of public and
private land in windy Southern Wyoming.
Since four squares of BLM land surround
every one patch of private land,
dealing with the feds is simply unavoidable.
Add all this up and any attempt to tap into this
treasure trove of wind power
should be dead in the water.
Who would gamble hundreds of millions of
dollars in upfront costs alone in the hopes
that America’s most conservative state
would sign off on clean energy and that
not one of a dozen counties or hundreds
of landowners would veto the project?
Enter billionaire oil tycoon,
Republican mega-donor,
and future owner of America’s
largest wind farm, Philip Anschutz.
His plan is to build 1,000 turbines,
capable of powering a million homes,
on 320,000 acres in a place
named for coal: “Carbon County”
A $3 billion 700-mile transmission line will then
connect this wind farm to California
through Colorado, Utah, and Nevada.
It took 18 years to secure the permits
but approval was finally granted,
against all odds, this spring.
Today, after a ten-year stagnation,
Wyoming wind is making a comeback.
About eight other farms are in development,
with most set to become
operational in the next 2 years.
Only one question remains: Will
the people of Wyoming allow it?
In the 1970s, the term “national sacrifice zone”
was coined to describe places like Wyoming.
Out here, on the country’s remote frontier,
a few Americans would endure the sight,
smell, and symptoms of coal so that
many more could enjoy its fruits.
In return, these areas were well compensated
with high salaries and low taxes.
But, for some, wind represents an unwelcome
renegotiation of that implicit trade.
According to the University of Wyoming,
wind will bring somewhere between three
and nine thousand jobs to the state
– not at all an insignificant amount.
The overwhelming majority, however, are short-term
construction jobs – building access roads,
transporting parts, and installing equipment.
In the long term, there may only be 500 to
1,500 operations and maintenance roles – a
drop in the bucket compared to coal, oil, and gas.
Now, Wyoming residents are powerless to
stop the spread of green energy – just
as global oil prices have long
dictated the state of its economy.
But there is one thing they can do: tax it.
Wyoming is already the only state in the union
with a wind tax. Currently $1 per megawatt-hour,
several politicians have proposed
raising it to 2, 3, 4, or even $5.
It’s effectively playing a high-stakes
game of chicken with wind developers.
Wyoming is betting that its wind is so good
that investors will swallow the extra cost.
And if it works, the tax could breathe new life
into Wyoming’s dying economy. By introducing
a new source of revenue, the state could
begin weaning itself off of fossil fuels.
But if Wyoming overplays its hand and
developers take their money to Colorado
or New Mexico instead, its economy could
be left more dependent on coal than ever.
Perhaps the place in the world most
similar to Wyoming is Baotou, China.
In fact, it’s hard to distinguish these clips
of its coal mines from those of
Wyoming’s North Antelope mine.
Baotou is also, in all likelihood,
where the rare earth metals found
in the device you’re watching
this very video on, originated.
For years, China was accused of artificially
subsidizing their production for political
control. But the real reason for China’s
near monopoly is much more complicated.
Find out why in my six-part
Original series “China,
Actually” – exclusively available on Nebula.
Nebula is what happens when channels like
PolyMatter, RealLifeLore, RealEngineering,
and Wendover Productions are given extra resources
and freedom from the algorithm – longer, better,
and higher-production videos than
we could ever make on YouTube.
Take a look, for example, at Modern Conflicts.
These are 20, 30, 50-minute highly-researched
deep dives into recent global conflicts. This
is an insane amount of premium content and yet
it’s just one of dozens of Originals, all
available for just a few bucks a month.
…Normally $5 a month. But, you
can get it for 50% off – that’s
just $2.50 a month – by clicking the
link on screen or in the description.